DeVoe is about to reset all of our
brains what we really need is a meanness
Amunet is immune to Devoe's powers we
can partner up without Unitas is a
criminal she kidnapped you she tried to
sell me into metal sleep and she ruined
my bachelorette party
we need your help
no killing stipulation fine it is
time-consuming to remove blood from
metal Larry you have the floor no chance
Harry no way come on come on do the
intro why no 421 Harry and the Harrisons
the more I try to use my brain the
sooner I'm going to lose it nobody has
been able to sort of figure out how to
help Harry get his intelligence back ah
they bring in counselor Wells who now
that they see that Harry is in a dum-dum
as they call him they don't have any
time for him his face facts have lost
most of my science lost most of my math
language will be next there's nothing we
can do about it on the contrary Mon
frère e there's a whole multiverse of
Harrison wells out there that are all
smart let's go find them we'll get a new
council you know be the bee Harry in the
Harrisons I get a man boo you neither
wait so I'm not the only one uh-huh all
of us been kicked out all of you have
been kicking got me a counselor rejects
[Music]
everybody is Charlie we got new flash
and DC Universe TV shows and that
streaming service to talk about that's
right Titans a Swamp Thing live-action
TV show Young Justice season 3 and that
Harley Quinn show so I'll try to explain
what's going on because there's a whole
bunch of news that dropped this morning
so if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos there's a new round of that flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter just be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll also try to
talk more about coffee shop girl from
the end of last week's episode too but
next week's episode is mostly all about
Harrison wells it's called Harry and the
Harrison's it's also about them getting
Amunet blacks help in dealing with the
thinker I totally love Katee Sackhoff
but I just feel like the Amunet black
character just has not worked out this
season and she was a big character
during the comic book arc involving the
thinker during geoff johns era but the
way they used her was a little bit
different like she was the leader of the
Rogues during that era but then at the
end of that story captain cold showed up
and says looks like you guys need a real
leader and it was sort of a kick in the
pants to the Rogues as characters from
Captain Cold he was whipping them into
shape like okay now we're really
stepping our game up but they kind of
taken
the captain cold character in a
completely different direction I haven't
been really happy with the way that
they've dealt with some of the Rogues on
the TV show if you haven't seen it the
title is a play on the movie Harry and
the Hendersons which is sort of like a
Bigfoot movie with John Lithgow it's a
bit of a family comedy I don't know if
they're just borrowing the title because
it sounds funny and it has something to
do with the Council of wells or if
there'll be some similarities between
the plot of that movie in the plot of
this episode the copy shop girl most of
you have probably seen the episode by
now or if you haven't seen my video have
noticed that her lightening is both
yellow and purple you know bit of berry
lightening bit of iris West Lightning
just making you wonder who she belongs
to she's from the future
she's very clearly related to the West
Allen family but when she's talking to
Jones to seal about how precious the
time that they have now is it makes it
sound like she's one generation removed
like she's someone's daughter from
inside this room here but even though
they really want you to wonder if it's
the seals baby because she's having a
baby girl and there's all this pink
there she's wearing pink when she knocks
on the door and obviously she's a big
season five storyline they might be a
little misleading because remember
earlier this season they had Cecile on
the table and Caitlin's like yep nope
your baby's totally normal so because
that moment came after we learned about
coffee shop girl I think that was meant
to head off theories about them
potentially having a baby that was
coffee shop girl because think about it
this way like why would they let those
characters have a baby on this TV show
when they're like secondary characters
to begin with the reason why Jo
originally got with Cecile I think was
to give Jo something else to do when he
wasn't in scenes with Barry like what's
Joe doing when he's not on screen oh
he's off with Cecile previously there
just wasn't a lot in Jesse Martin's
storyline outside of Wally West so when
the wally story wasn't real Big Joe
wasn't real big
so when comes to seal the actresses
great Jesse Martin's one of the best
actors on the TV show so they have good
scenes together so I think they tried to
turn that into something a little bit
more but when you think about what the
flash TV show is all about it's about
Barry becoming the flash then getting
married to Iris and then starting a
family of speedsters that leads to the
flash family in the future what does Joe
and Cecile having a baby have to do with
that absolutely nothing so you're like
okay wait a minute are they
trying to do some twist I was one of
them gonna die is the baby gonna die
what's going on here the coffee shop
girls scene from last week's episode
makes it sound like something really bad
is gonna happen to either Joe or Cecile
maybe both of them because the
conversation she has with them is the
conversation you have with someone who's
dead in the future that you then go back
to a period when they were alive and say
treasure the time that you have while
you have it moving into DC universe
streaming service now everybody wants to
know Swamp Thing TV show what's going on
with Titans when is this all starting so
if you didn't see this morning they
announced that the untitled DC streaming
service where they're gonna be dropping
Titans and all these new shows that
they're developing is now officially
called DC Universe it'll be a
subscription service just like Netflix
or anything else but they haven't
announced what's gonna be happening
outside of the United States like right
now this sounds like it's gonna be
United States only and then they'll
partner up with Netflix for
international air dates so if you live
in Europe or somewhere else and you're
watching these DC TV shows that are on
the CW on Netflix on a weekly basis
pretty good bet that that's also how
you're probably going to be watching
Titans and these other new DC shows that
they're developing so we knew about
Titans they're filming now we actually
found out that Donna Troy is probably
gonna be a character that will recur
during season one and be a main
character during season two looks like a
pretty solid pick can't wait to see what
she actually looks like in costume but
they're still filming that TV show
everything seems to be going pretty
normally they posted more behind the
scenes pictures of Hawk and Dove in
their costume I guess they're back on
set for one of the later episodes they
still have a couple episodes left to
film Robyn was back in his costume
within all the announcements that they
were making they released logos for the
TV show like this is the logo for the
Titans TV show like this is the logo for
the flash TV show this is the logo for
Young Justice season 3 this is the logo
for that animated Harley Quinn TV show
that they're doing and this is the logo
for the new Swamp Thing live-action show
that they announced so they announced
the James Wan who's doing the Aquaman
movie is executive producing this
live-action Swamp Thing TV show it'll
probably be 13 episodes they say it's
probably gonna drop during 2019 sometime
so they didn't say what the story is
going to be they'll probably tell his
origin story the same way they're doing
the origin story of the Titans so
if you're really big swampthing fan or
you want to read stories I would just
recommend starting with rebirth if
you're looking for specific comic book
stories to read to get ready I wouldn't
worry about that too much now just find
something that you like and start
reading that it's gonna be a while
before we get more news about Swamp
Thing they gave it a script to series
order meaning that if the network likes
the script they will give it a full
series order and they'll just start
making it but the people that are
writing that script are from Battlestar
Galactica in the it movie so if James
Wan is a notable horror director and you
have a horror person writing it along
with Battlestar Galactica it sounds like
the Swamp Thing TV show is gonna be
straight-up horror which makes me so
much more excited about it so I almost
forgot there's actually that metropolis
TV show - they didn't make any special
announcements about that they didn't
reveal a logo for what it's gonna look
like I think because they're trying to
figure out how Superman is gonna figure
into it and they want to work him into
the logo if they can but the only TV
shows out of all this stuff that are
gonna drop this year are Titans and
Young Justice season 3 everything else
that you just heard about isn't gonna
drop till next year
so by 2019 we'll have like a couple of
these hardcore DC shows on and they're
meant to be way more hardcore than the
network stuff the CW does they have
broadcast standards that they adhere to
when shows are made specifically for
streaming platforms you don't have to
worry about that you can show more blood
more sex more of all the good stuff so
what will happen later this year before
Comic Con is they might announce their
pricing model and when they're gonna
roll shows out but I think that they're
on track to show off trailers for some
of this stuff especially Young Justice
and Titans when we get to comic-con but
because this is just the beginning
post all your questions in the comments
below I'm sure there's thousands of
questions about how this is all gonna
work who are they gonna get to play
Swamp Thing how are the show's gonna
crossover or are they going to have
anything to do with what's going on with
the CW DC TV shows so as we learn more I
will do more videos about that
congratulations to agent 1207 you're the
giveaway winner from my last video
please private message me so I can get
your contact details and yes to answer
your question that is who coffee girl is
so click here for my flash episode from
last night and click here for brand new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you
guys tonight